Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard schönen
guten Morgen Markus wie geht's dir bist
du auch ich bin ich bin so ein bisschen
immer noch so ein nasal wirst du so ein
bisschen angehört
wahrscheinlich so ganz viel hoch und so
sehr gut womit beschäftigst du dich
gerade Richard was machst du gerade was
ich so was Philosophen so am Morgen
machen ich gucke den Parteitag der
chinesischen Kaffee den im Oktober war
mein Sohn hatte Dich in meinem Verdacht
der neue irgendeiner im Westen muss das
ja mal gucken er ist natürlich mein äh
Chinesisch auch nicht mehr das was uns
mal war nein ich habe mir nur einen
kleinen Ausschnitt angeguckt und zwar
diese legendäre Szene wo huhu jeden Tag
Präsident ja ja jetzt müssen wir gucken
wie wir es formulieren
betreut ich würde mich abgeführt hört
mich freuen
geführt wurde so in der FAZ stand er
wäre aus dem Saal gezerrt worden danke
er nicht ich habe gelesen er wurde
abgeführt das ist auch schon eine
ziemlich ziemlich steile Interpretation
des Ganzen und vor dem Haus auch danach
herausgeführt finde ich gut und dann ist
es vorhin danach erst verschwunden ich
sehe diese ganzen westlichen
Journalisten die in sechs Wochen lang
gesucht haben bis er dann beim Begräbnis
wieder aufgetaucht ist also ich weiß
nicht wie man als westlicher
Korrespondent feststellt ob jemand in
China verschwunden ist ja also das kann
man ja nur dadurch dass jemand sich an
seine Fersen geheftet hat und dann ist
er in irgendeine dunkle Männer abgeführt
worden und sechs Wochen lang nicht mehr
aufgetaucht aber die spannende Frage
damals im Oktober gesehen als Ausschnitt
in sämtlichen deutschen
Nachrichtensendungen und auch drüber
gelesen ja es gab keine große Zeitung
die darüber nicht berichtet hätte und
eben erzählt er wieder abgeführt wurde
oder eben sogar wie die FHZ schreibt aus
dem Raum gezerrt
so jetzt habe ich mir das Bild heute
Morgen und die Bilder immer wieder und
immer wieder angeguckt die längst der
Version geht etwas über zwei Minuten da
kann man den Kontext so ein bisschen
ersehen vorher der Herren links neben
ihm auch irgendein bedeutender Kaffee
funktioniert dessen Namen ich natürlich
nicht kenne der redet erstmal mit ihm
und da liegt da so ein roter Mappe auf
dem Tisch dann schiebt er die rote Mappe
zu sich und dann gibt's da so ein hin
und her mit der roten Mappe und dann
kommt irgendwann kommt dann jemand der
ihn da raus geleitet und dann greift
ähm ja noch mal nach seiner Roten Mappe
und dann wird ihm so ein bisschen
weggenommen und dann wird er so da so
rausgeschoben und der wirkt mich
versuche meinen neutral zu sagen
verwirrt das glaube ich der hauptein und
verstört verwirrt so ein bisschen als
wenn mich nicht klar was ihm da gerade
geschieht genau also das würde ich mal
sagen ist so das was man so ungefähr
ohne wissen wenn man sieht noch ein
bisschen
er redet ja auch noch mal mit ja der
dreht sich noch mal rum zu ihm und der
lächelt ihm zu ne und nickend so macht
so eine freundliche Geste so nach dem
Motto das ist alles so in Ordnung wie es
ist also so würde man es interpretieren
ne da wird auch geredet nur ist das sind
alle diese Versionen also da hört man
nicht was da gesprochen wird man hört
zum danebengeräusche und so ich glaube
es sind Bilder von AFD und gefilmt wurde
das deswegen weil vorher knapp vorher
sogar die westlichen Medien die ja
normalerweise auf dem Parteitag ziemlich
außen vor sind
reingelassen wurden in den Parteitag so
dass sie als erstes quasi dieses Szene
mitbekommen haben so und jetzt bin ich
total gespannt auf die Pointe Richert
naja die Pointe ist das in diesen ganzen
Filmen die ich gesehen habe
interpretiert wurde es ginge um
folgendes in der roten Mappe oder unter
diese roten Klarsichthülle da wäre quasi
das künftige Kabinett von Präsidentin
und die Verteilung Vollmachten und so
weiter drin gewesen und das wäre mit
Sicherheit etwas gewesen
was ihm nicht gefallen hätte ja also was
Gin Taro nicht gemocht hätte weil er als
Vertreter des Kollektivismus diese
starke Stellung des Präsidenten sicher
nicht unterstützt hätte das ist so die
Interpretation und dass man deswegen
eine Art Exempel statuiert hätte so wie
man das früher von Stalin kennt ja dass
man bevor er zur Abstimmung kommt
sozusagen öffentlich vor all dem 1.000
2000 weiß nicht wie viele sind KP
Delegierten da abgeführt wird
rausgeführt wird um zu sagen so du hast
darüber hier nichts mehr zu bestimmen ja
du wirst jetzt mal entfernt und dann ist
er ja angeblich sechs Wochen
verschwunden
so und diese Version habe ich jetzt in
quasi eins zu eins Übereinstimmung bei
von zahlreichen Korrespondenten die dann
da in China waren übrigens die meisten
nicht auf dem Parteitag natürlich na so
viel westliche sind da gar nicht
zugelassen meistens westlichen
korpulenten können wahrscheinlich auch
nicht so fließen Chinesisch und
verfolgen da auch nicht die ganzen reden
mit aber wie dem auch sei es wurde
überall übereinstimmt eben von der
Machtdemonstration von Präsident
geschrieben so jetzt hatte ich ja
unlängst eine Sendung mit frankieren und
habe ihn darauf angesprochen ne Frage
China jetzt will ich natürlich wissen ja
die Sendung ich habe die gesehen sehr
empfehlenswert in der Mediathek in
abrufbar ich ich habe sie mir angesehen
und war vor allen Dingen verblüfft wie
unvergleichlich gut und Jugend daraus
bereit und dachte wieder dachte wieder
älter zu werden ist auch eine Frage der
richtigen Beleuchtung finde ich auch
sagen also sie haben wahrscheinlich gut
geschminkt und so weiter ja und dann
gehe ich jetzt auch zu den Leuten die
sich dann irgendwann wenn sie sich im
Fernsehen sehen nicht mehr erkennen
genau wie ein dynamischer end40er sehr
schön
wie man die Öffentlichkeit hinter die
Fichte führen kann so und eben zum Thema
Öffentlichkeit und Manipulation jetzt
eben ich frage frankieren und der sagt
ja gut der Mann ist über 80 ja und dem
ging es nicht gut die haben gemerkt der
ist irgendwie ein bisschen konfus und
und vielleicht irgendwie nicht mehr ganz
klar und Volkskongress dauert ja auch
gar nicht nee eigentlich keine Überblick
mehr und dann sind die halt haben die
ihn halt freundlich ja also für sorglich
ihrer hinaus Leute
und jetzt möchte man natürlich wissen
mein Gott
und dafür muss man ja eines wissen woher
wissen die Leute die darüber urteilen
was er genau passiert wir werden es
nicht mehr erklären können
ich war ja lange in der Jury vom Henry
nannten Preis ne ich kann ja nur jeden
investigativen Journalisten auffordern
sich da mal hinter zu klemmen und Licht
in dieses Dunkel zu bringen weil ich
finde es wahnsinnig wichtig ich möchte
weißt du es geht am Ende nicht um
hugentau ja
sondern es geht um die Frage wenn wir
darüber berichten von solchen
Ereignissen und daraus ja sehr
weitreichende Schlussfolgerungen ziehen
ob die ihm richtig oder falsch sind
können wir nicht beurteilen und das
eigentlich das ist was von den Parteitag
der KP mir hängengeblieben ist in der
Berichterstattung unserer Medien ja also
ah dass ich diktatorische Vollmachten
gemacht hat dann dass er vor sich einer
sich verschaffenen Weltlage und großen
Schwierigkeiten gewarnt hat und dass er
diesen Mann hat abführen lassen das sind
sozusagen die drei Punkte die in
Erinnerung waren weil die überall
genannt wurden
dann muss ganz wichtig sein dass diese
Informationen in dieser Form stimmt und
dann möchte ich eben genau wissen wenn
dann jemand ne so überzeugt ist wie
Adria Geiges der großer China Kenner ist
wenn der so fest überzeugt ist woher er
seine feste Überzeugung nimmt das würde
ich gerne wissen weil das bisher ist
alles Interpretation genau Richard China
also was wir auf jeden Fall merken und
ich Sachen in den Reaktionen auf die
Sendung gemerkt das Thema fasziniert die
Leute wahnsinnig in fasziniert vor allen
Dingen auch junge Leute wir hatten auch
Mitternacht noch sehr viel wirklich sehr
junges Publikum
dabei die haben sich das angesehen und
ich habe mit wissen liebe Grüße an der
Stelle immer unser großartiger Amerika
Korrespondent ist ZDFs hat noch länger
darüber gesprochen der sagt es gibt so
eine es gibt so ein Jahres Datum es gibt
2008 da haben die Chinesen erstmals
angefangen wirklich die Amerikaner
sehr sehr offen herauszufordern das war
sozusagen merkbar da passiert jetzt was
und da hat sich sozusagen die
seribilität immer weiter aufgeschaukelt
bis zu dem Punkt an dem wir heute sind
wo wir merken okay da passiert jetzt
etwas
dass das Wettrennen zwar ja Supermächte
da werden sich Machtverhältnisse auf der
Welt verschieben und
jemand wie Elmar der sehr kluger Mann
ist und sein Ohr ganz nah an Washington
dran hat dann Washingtoner Politik der
sagt habe immer im Hinterkopf die
Tatsache dass die Amerikaner die Ukraine
so unterstützen wie sie es tun hat nicht
nur was mit der Ukraine zu tun sondern
es hat ganz viel mit Taiwan zu tun also
die Aussage jetzt erstmal nicht also ich
weiß ich weiß nicht ich weiß ja dass
also sehr sehr viele Leute die Amerika
gut kennen gesagt haben der eigentliche
Gegner ja für die große
Auseinandersetzung um 21 Jahrhundert ist
aus US-amerikanischer Perspektive nicht
wirtschaftlich nicht bedeuten genug
genau
eine eine Zwischenetappe ja oder oder
sozusagen ein Vorgeplänkel in der ganz
großen Auseinandersetzung mit China und
es gibt offensichtlich bei den Leuten
die also da strategische Überlegungen
machen die sind diesen ganzen Think
Tanks sehr sehr viel mehr Leute die sich
mit China beschäftigen als ich mit die
sich mit Russland beschäftigen genau
weil das ist eigentlich so den der das
große Armageddon ja was man im Auge hat
dass er sozusagen dieser dieser
Wettkampf ich will ja nicht hoffen
Endkampf aber Wettkampf mit China genau
und und er sagt eben ne Taiwan der ist
die Lektion die für die Chinesen
sozusagen drin sein muss wenn es um die
Ukraine geht ist wir werden uns das
genau angucken was ihr da macht und
deswegen lassen wir Putin nicht davon
kommen wir würden euch im Zweifel auch
nicht davon kommen lassen weil es um die
Chip Industrie vor allem von Taiwan geht
aber auch um die Meere Engel an sich das
Südchinesische Meer und so weiter man
schließt dort neue Allianzen die
Amerikaner sind plötzlich du erinnerst
dich es gab vor zwei Jahren gab es so
Simulationen des amerikanischen Militärs
und da waren die völlig fassungslos
darüber dass sie in diesen Simulationen
einen möglichen Krieg gegen China
verloren hätten das haben wir aber
mittlerweile wieder weggemacht haben
Allianzen geschlossen mit den
Philippinen mit den Japanern haben
selber unglaublich aufgerüstet dass ein
richtiges Wettrüsten im Gange die
Chinesen haben die größte Marine die
größte Kriegsflotte der Welt
mittlerweile und wenn man sich mal
sozusagen die Eckdaten anguckt
Ballons die plötzlich abgeschossen
werden amerikanische Bürgermeister in
nordkakota zum Beispiel eine schöne
Geschichte gelesen der ganz ganz ganz
ganz stolz darauf war dass die Chinesen
im November 2021
bei denen eine
meistverarbeitungsanlage errichten
wollten
kleiner Ort 60.000 Einwohner und alle
sagten wunderbar da kommt jetzt der neue
Investor amerikanische Arbeitsplätze
egal auch wenn es dich Chinesen sind und
seit der ballongeschichte ist das Ding
vom Tisch und die sagen wenn es um
nationale Sicherheit geht dann darf
Wirtschaft keine Rolle spielen das sagen
ihr Amerikaner ja die die Aufgabe können
das hier drittgrößte Handelspartner ja
das ist der Punkt und das ist ja eben
der ganz große Unterschied
frankieren sagt immer wir können China
nicht mehr bedrohen oder erpressen
ja also früher wäre das möglich gewesen
bis vor 20 Jahren vielleicht aber jetzt
erst recht nicht mehr das heißt also man
man wird das ja nicht dadurch los dass
man sagt wir gehen jetzt in die große
Konfrontation also einerseits
militärisch wenn man sich nicht ausmalen
was passiert würde wenn es im
südchinesischen mehr zum Krieg käme
da sie verheerenden Auswirkungen für die
Welt das das wäre ja noch eine ganz
andere wirtschaftliche Detonation als
dieser indirekte Krieg mit Russland das
kann man ihn gar nichts miteinander
vergleichen muss ich ja nur mal so eine
schöne Zahl vor Augen führen das knapp
40% aller Autos die die deutsche
Automobilhersteller in China verkauft
werden
man stelle sich mal vor die 40 Prozent
würden wegfallen was damit der deutschen
Automobilindustrie losfährt und das ist
doch nur ein Beispiel unter ganz ganz
vielen Beispielen das heißt also
Wirtschaftskrieg mit China das würde
wäre sozusagen das Ende des Wohlstandes
auch im Westen genau und deswegen ist
das ja keine Option und eine
militärische Auseinandersetzung braucht
man nicht drüber zu reden wäre auch
keine Option richtig und trotzdem läuft
es auf beides sukzessive zu
möglicherweise auch nicht die die die
Chinesen sind ja das das kann man sich
auch angucken schreibt auch Ferrari in
seinen Lektionen fürs 21 Jahrhundert die
haben das zeigt doch die ganze
Geschichte die haben wenig Kriege nach
außen geführt das ist sehr interessant
wirklich smarte Völker führen keine
Kriege und wenn du heute schaust
wirklich prosperierende Länder auf der
Welt ja das sind die Länder die lange
keine Kriege gewählt haben
zum Beispiel aber ich habe pass auf ich
les dir mal was vor in der
Weltgeschichte gab es eine Reihe von
Hochkulturen zum Beispiel im heutigen
Iran Irak also Mesopotamien ja früher
zwei stromland genannt Hochkulturen der
Inkas toltheken als Theken in Südamerika
Hochkulturen in Indien und Ägypten die
chinesische Hochkultur bis zwischen 4000
und 5000 Jahren alt und das Besondere an
ihr ist sie lebt immer noch obwohl sie
uralt ist warum ist das so und warum
sind alle anderen untergegangen das
finde ich eine so guten Text ein Teil
aus einem aus einem Interview mit Helmut
Schmidt der glaube ich 15 Mal in China
war und der vor allen Dingen fasziniert
er war nicht begeistert aber war
fasziniert und neugierig
genau weil immer sagte dieses Land ist
so ganz anders und es ist ein
gigantisches Experiment dass da gerade
läuft Ausgang sozusagen offen
es gibt auch viele Schwächen in China da
reden wir bestimmt gleich noch drüber
aber wenn du dir zum Beispiel mal
anschaust so eine Stadt wie Shenzhen ja
nicht weit von Hongkong ich meine vor 40
Jahren und das macht alles so klar ein
Fischerdorf 30.000 Leute heute leben da
80 Millionen Menschen ja und zwar mit
E-Autos der Verkehr zu 100% elektrisch
der öffentliche Nahverkehr komplett mit
Ökostrom die ersten autonomen Fahrzeuge
16.000 e-busse
22.000 e-taxis unzählige Elektroroller
das ist die Welthauptstadt der
E-Mobilität
5g wurde dort entwickelt wenn Nokia und
Ericsson heute 5g Technologie
ausprobieren wollen haben sie gar keine
andere Wahl als dort hinzugehen und das
mit Entwicklern aus Shenzen zu machen
und was ich so interessant finde
unfassbar jung zusammen mit mumbai ist
diese Mega City die niedrigste Stadt auf
der Welt die auf der Welt 29 Jahre im
Vergleich dazu London im Schnitt 35 New
York 36 Berlin und Hongkong 43
das ist das was da passiert und und
diese diese Entwicklung
weil so viele junge Leute zugezogen sind
aus aller Welt auch das junge Amerikaner
zum Beispiel sehr wichtig richtig
richtig
und das das finde ich halt so
faszinierend
gleichzeitig unsere Abhängigkeit ich
meine wir reden die ganze Zeit davon und
sagen na wir müssen aufpassen dieses
deutsche wohlstandsmodell ist ja schwer
unter die Räder gekommen ja das stand ja
auf zwei Säulen haben wir schon ein paar
darüber gesprochen billige Energie aus
Russland und auf der anderen Seite
dieser gigantische chinesische Markt und
wir müssen da jetzt aufpassen denke an
die Diskussion und den Hamburger Hafen
die Kappeln wir müssen uns unabhängiger
machen die Wahrheit ist der Handel der
deutschen Wirtschaft mit China ist im
vergangenen Jahr auf einen neuen
Rekordwert gestellt
98 Milliarden Euro das ein Wachstum von
21 Prozent gegenüber 2021 das musst du
dir mal klar machen also dass das Geld
geht dahin wo die Zukunft ist ne und
genau das andere was wir politisch vor
allem verlautbaren lassen ich meine das
sind immer zwei verschiedene Dinge ne
also ich meine die Generationen vom
bundeskanzern alle nach Helmut Schmidt
der das ja nicht gemacht und der hat die
Chinesen natürlich mit einem anderen
Blick gesehen
alle alle
Politikerin und die jonalisten sowieso
naja jedenfalls
abgesehen von Helmut Schmidt
danach haben also Aldi
Bundeskanzler also immer ihre
Pflichtaufgabe getan während die Mini
Medien dabei sind drei Sätze über die
Menschenrechte zu verlieren und
anschließend hat man immer weiter
wachsende Geschäfte gemacht und dazu
gibt es wahrscheinlich auch keine
Alternative und ich möchte einen
Gedanken von frankieren der mir neu war
ne der mich ins Nachdenken gebracht hat
der ja auch sagt natürlich ist das so
ich meine wir wollen lieber unsere Werte
haben als die Werte Chinas und es gibt
ja Dinge die wir tatsächlich nicht
miteinander teilen und wir haben einen
deutlich umfassendere Vorstellung von
Menschenrechten von Pressefreiheit
individueller Freiheit und so weiter und
so weiter nur wenn wir die in die
werkschale liegen wollen
ist eine Bedingung unabdingbar
wir müssen wirtschaftlichen Erfolg haben
kein Mensch übernimmt Werte von
Verlierern also nur wenn wir zeigen dass
wir mit diesen Werten wirtschaftlich zu
den erfolgreichsten Nationen der Welt
gehören nur dann werden die anderen uns
wenn wir über diese Werte reden
überhaupt ernst nehmen
sollten wir aber ein wirtschaftlichen
Abstieg hinlegen werden wir auch unsere
Werte global nicht irgendwo durchsetzen
oder schmackhaft machen können und das
ist glaube ich eine richtig wichtige
Lektion da habe ich vorher überhaupt gar
nicht drüber nachgedacht aber da ist was
dran definitiv und ich glaube auch
ehrlich gesagt wenn Du Dir mal anguckst
und deswegen ist das ja so spannend zu
sehen was da gerade passiert ne die die
Südafrikaner machen gerade ein großes
Militärmanöver in diesen Tagen und die
Amerikaner wollten mitmachen die haben
sie einfach ausgeladen gesagt wollen wir
nicht wir machen das lieber mit den
Chinesen und mit den Russen da
verschiebt sich was und ich ich habe das
Gefühl das hat auch was damit zu tun
dass sie sich der Westen vor allem die
Amerikaner haben sich in den letzten
Jahrzehnten größtenteils auch durch
eigenes Verschulden mit vielen Ländern
un zwar verscherzt also wenn du diese
allein diese diese Anmaßung im Irak die
Demokratie amerikanischer Prägung
einzuführen zum Beispiel ja
ernst gemeint war das ist noch mal eine
Frage zur sicher aber zumindestens
offiziell genau verkündet und dann
gleichzeitig benötigen will und
gleichzeitig begehst du unglaubliche
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und echte
Kriegsverbrechen die du dann auch noch
versuchst zu verschleiern ja das heißt
richtige Doppelstandards dann ist das
schwierig und Stichwort Glaubwürdigkeit
des Westens erinnerst du dich es gab
diese Geschichte letztes Jahr was glaube
ich im Juni wenn man im Sommer auf jeden
Fall Amerika Gipfel
da hat Joe Biden zu einem Amerika-Gipfel
eingeladen und hat was auf Kuba
Nicaragua und Venezuela ausgeladen mit
der Begründung sie sei nicht
demokratisch genug also Stichwort Werte
geleitete Außenpolitik und wir sind ja
die guten natürlich und interessant war
was dann passiert ist änderst du dich
Mexiko hat daraufhin gesagt okay wenn
ich so arrogant sind dann kommen wir
auch nicht ja und die die die Chinesen
sind da natürlich deutlich flexibler und
sagen pass auf auch den Afrikanern
müsste jetzt nicht gleich unbedingt den
Kommunismus einführen wir bringen euch
aber erstmal eine eine Straße eine
Klinik und und Strom der nicht jeden Tag
zusammenbricht und ein Kredit kriegt die
auch noch also das heißt wir exportieren
Ideologie oder ideale meinetwegen
demokratische ideale ja Moral und
teilweise wirklich auch Moralismus und
auch Scheinheiligkeit und Chinesen gehen
da sehr viel pragmatisch daran und da
habe ich das Gefühl da passiert gerade
was wie siehst du das Richard also es
gibt ja interessante Parallele zwischen
China und Henry Kissinger
ja also je älterkissenger wird umso mehr
erinnerte mich an die Chinesen oder ein
Chinesen haben ihn als Lehrmeister
genommen also der der alte Kissinger von
heute vertritt ja die Ansicht Länder
sollten mit ihren Werten nicht hausieren
gehen genauso wie Helmut Schmidt das
meinte sondern Länder haben Interessen
und die sollten Sie so geschickt wie
möglich vertreten
und das Interessante ist eben dass die
chinesische Politik eine strengstens
interessens geleitete Politik ist also
es gibt ja nicht viel ideologisches
Politik wir reden jetzt nicht ähm China
nach ihnen ne da in dem was die Leute
traktiert werden sondern anders als das
z.B der Westen macht in der christlichen
Tradition ne der Kreuzfahrer und so
weiter wir missionieren ja mit unseren
Werten das haben wir von Christentum
genommen weil wir wollen ja dass die
ganze Welt so wird wie wir und das ist
etwas was sich Chinesen nicht machen
also die versuchen ja nicht uns vom
Kommunismus zu bekehren oder wie auch
immer die ihre Gesellschaftsform nennen
diese Mischung aus Raubtier Kapitalismus
Kommunismus und so ein bisschen
konfrontierenistische Würze ne sondern
das machen die alles nicht sondern es
wird ja möglichst geschickt versucht
Interessen zu verfolgen also im besten
Sinne machiavilismus zu betreiben
das übrigens interessant mal aufzuräumen
mit den Vorurteilen gegen Machiavelli
javelli gilt ja immer so als der große
böse Schweinehund der so dem Fürsten
gesagt hat du musst jede miesende Finte
und jeden bösen Trick oder so machen um
dich durchzusetzen aber tatsächlich war
für die damalige Zeit was ungewöhnlich
Machiavelli ein Republikaner und was er
nicht wollte war wertegeleitete Politik
das war sein Feind und Werte geleitete
politik bedeutet damals christliche
Politik zum Beispiel na wir reden über
das Kind Mittelalter Anfang der
Renaissance und wir reden über Italien
ne wir reden über Italien in der
damaligen Zeit und sein Vorbild war die
römische Republik die eben auch nicht
Werte geleitet war sondern die nur ihre
Interessen verfolgt hat und das war die
Grundlage für die Idee mit dem mit dem
Fürsten zu sagen Realpolitik betreiben
immer auf die Interessen gucken ja
kühles eiskaltes Schachspiel
aber sich nicht irgendwie hitzig in
irgendwas reinziehen lassen oder
persönliche Präferenzen und
Weltanschauungen damit reinmischen und
und und und das beschreibt relativ gut
wie die chinesische Außenpolitik
funktioniert und das ist eben die große
Gemeinsamkeit so Henry Kissinger werden
anders als das in seiner früheren Zeit
mal war ich sag mal Vietnamkrieg und so
weiter ist er ja auch ein absoluter
Vertreter von eiskaltem Schach in der
Außenpolitik und mit dem raushalten von
starken Werte übrigens genau muss gerade
an an gibt so ein chinesischen Satz der
mir hängen geblieben ist sie immer zu
deine Kraft zu verbergen zeigt nicht wie
stark du wirklich bist aber das hat sich
ja gründlich geändert ne wir haben mal
von drüber gesprochen dass so ungefähr
ab 2018 Chinesen die Amerikaner ganz
offensiv herausfordern das beginnt oft
mit auch mit dem Aufstieg von Ping ich
weiß nicht ob du dich erinnerst es gibt
diese Geschichte Obama auf Staatsbesuch
in PE 216 die Sache mit der Flugzeug
drin erinnerst du dich daran ich meine
überleg doch mal es geht muss man
vielleicht kurz erzählen ja so Barmer
landet in Peking und es geht um die
Frage wie steigt der jetzt aus der Air
Force One aus diesem Flugzeug aus und
die Amerikaner legen offensichtlich bei
Staatsbesuchen Wert darauf dass der
Präsident über die eigene über eine
amerikanische Treppe aussteigt warum
auch immer das schon
sicherheit stimmt
jeder Staatspräsident würde darauf
bestehen ja du die fahren auch mit ihren
eigenen Autos durch die Welt ich habe
das hier in Hamburg damals erlebt wie
die zwei Karren für Donald Trump
eingeflogen worden sind
warum auch immer auf jeden Fall diese
Treppe scheint ein mörderisches Ding zu
sein und die Chinesen hatten diese
Treppe nicht ich glaube sie wollten sie
nicht haben und der chinesische
zuständige schiebt dann diese
chinesische Treppe an und die Amerikaner
sagen die steigen wenn ich aus das geht
neben mir nicht gesagt ich habe aber
keine andere ist wirklich dann mein
Flugzeug meine Treppe und auf der
anderen Seite aber unser Flughafen und
unsere Treppe ja wir haben das doof
deswegen nicht wieder abfliegen wie
gesagt der amerikanische Präsident war
beleidigt war da nicht über seine eigene
Treffer aussteigen durfte dann steht man
nicht gut da aber darf auch nicht
nachgeben genau erst stieg nicht aus
Obama bleibt ewig lange in diesem
Flugzeug holen und stieg nicht aus und
ich glaube der Kompromiss war dann am
Ende es wurde dann doch die eigene die
amerikanische Treppe genommen ja aber
hinten raus hinten raus genau und
Beobachter weisen darauf hin und sagen
20 Jahre vorher als Bill Clinton da war
da haben die amerikanischen Beamten die
die Chinesen rumgeschubst wie sonst was
und haben den sind dort aufgetreten wie
Graf guckt in der Gasanstalt und haben
den irgendwie klar gemacht das läuft
hier nach unseren Regeln das ist
sozusagen vorbei ja das ist ein schönes
singt ja total also sind wir wieder bei
dem Satz wir können nicht mehr bedrohen
und erpressen ja und ähm du sagst ja in
die offene Konfrontation gegangen also
sagen wir mal offen eigene
großmachtsansprüche angemeldet ja nach
dem Motto wir haben jetzt ein
wahnsinnigen wirtschaftlichen Aufstieg
hinter uns aber bislang haben wir uns
immer dahinter versteckt ne unsere
eigene Kraft nicht gezeigt so und jetzt
wird es Zeit 21 Jahrhundert und jetzt
müssen wir mal die politische
Topographie neu entwerfen und gucken wo
sind die großen Berge genau und dann
stellt man eben fest dass im USA zwar
noch immer ein großer Berg ist auch wenn
er so ein bisschen Gletscher artig
schmilzt und Europa genau dasselbe und
das ist eben andere große Berge gibt
China der größte davon aber es gibt ja
noch viele andere und dass das eben die
neue Topographie des 21 jahrhunderts ist
und das dann chinesische Perspektive
gleiches Recht für alle gelten soll
genau und die Perspektive Richard total
interessant ich meine wir Deutschen
glauben ja gerne dass die ganze Welt
über Greta Thunberg und Luisa Neubauer
redet und über Fridays for future und
über die letzte Generation und so weiter
das ist aber eine völlig
eurozentristische Sicht in China hat
kaum jemand jemals von Gre Thunberg
gehört und ich weiß nicht ob du ob du
das mal mitgekriegt hast wirklich kannte
das nicht es gibt chinesische
intellektuelle ein paar wenige die
können natürlich mit dem Namen Greta
thünenberg wie man sagt glaube ich was
anfangen und verspotten sie als Heldin
des weißen Blattes dann spielen damit
auf einen Studenten an während der
Kulturrevolution ja zwischen 66 und 76
ungefähr der bei einer Prüfung ein
leeres Blatt abgegeben hat und zwar mit
der Begründung es war wichtiger für
Maros Revolution zu kämpfen als zu
lernen
das total interessant dass die Reaktion
auf den Schuld steigt ja richtig so okay
aber lustig machen in der Bildung zurück
bleiben genau und und es gibt junge
chinesische Umweltaktivisten weil der
Umwelt auch für die Chinesen ein riesen
Thema heißt die sagen für junge Chinesen
gibt es andere Probleme als den
Klimawandel das ist absolut nicht unser
erstes Thema
darum wollte ich gerade hinaus also
interessantes aber unser Bild von China
ist sozusagen die die Umweltzerstörer
die Umweltsau den ist total egal ist
hauptsache das Geschäft läuft es gab ich
glaube auch Adrian Geiges war es unter
anderem der für den Stern mal eine große
Reportage 2005 gemacht hat
berichtet hat über einen 80 km langen
Teppich aus Benzol in Nordost China der
dadurch so eine 4 Millionenstadt
geflossen ist ja Menschen die damit in
Berührung gekommen sind sind sofort
gestorben ja der berühmte schwarze
Drache also so hieß dieser Fluss dich
Führung hat dann für deren Verhältnisse
sehr schnell reagiert nach 10 Tagen
haben sie den Leuten da mal gesagt dass
da ein Werk von Petrochina einfach in
die Luft geflogen ist das war damals der
größte Öl und Gas Produzent und da ist
einfach Benzol in diesem Fluss gekommen
oder an anderes Dorf beschreibt der wo
das Wasser plötzlich salzig schmeckte in
der Zeit und dann kochen die Leute mit
dem Wasser und dann färbt sich dieser
Kessel rot und dann kriegen sie
Durchfall und merken plötzlich alle
anderen haben das auch und einige Monate
später können sie alle ihre Beine nicht
mehr bewegen ja seine Frau die dann
plötzlich mit einer halbseitigen Lähmung
da sitzt 27 Dorfbewohner sterben
darunter ein 14-jähriges Mädchen das
ganze Dorf das ist schon krass wie ein
Sanatorium also alle humpeln an einem
Stock herum falls überhaupt noch gehen
können und so weiter dann gibt es ein
anderes Dorf dass er beschreibt wo eine
Glutamat Fabrik ja so dermaßen den Fluss
versaut das von von 2.400 Einwohnern
sterben innerhalb weniger Jahre über 100
an Krebs und erzählt von einer jungen
Frau die dann einen künstlichen
Darmausgang bekommt weil sie wegen ihres
Darm und Schilddrüsenkrebs ist Signal
operiert worden war und nach der 12
Runde Chemotherapie sagt ich kann das
jetzt nicht mehr bezahlen ich werde
jetzt sterben
und das ist der Preis den wir für diesen
sagenhaften Aufstieg hingelegt haben das
ist das Bild das sozusagen immer noch so
unser China Bild prägen das will ich
zwei Sachen sagen das eine ist es ist
nicht typisch chinesisch weil man sich
überlegen die was die Atomwaffentests in
den USA alles angerichtet haben ihre
eigene Bevölkerung mit Krebs
überzogen bis zum geht nicht mehr oder
man denkt an den Uranabbau in Bitterfeld
in der DDR also ich denke mal jedes Land
wird auf diese Sachen zurück gucken ja
auch wir was wir sozusagen früher mal
als unser Wasser reingelassen haben was
die Chemieindustrie bei uns alles früher
mal verseuchen durfte was sie heute
nicht mehr tut also die Zeit des
rasanten industriellen Aufstiegs ist
eigentlich immer verbunden mit einer
gewissen Menschen verachtenden
Umwelt Haltung ich glaube das gehört
zusammen und das zweite was ich dazu
anmerken will ist wir fanden das alle
lange gut wir fahren das nämlich
deswegen gut weil wir unsere Waren in
China so günstig produzieren konnten
weil die keine hohen unter anderem weil
die a keine hohen Umwelt Auflagen hatten
und B weil dann Menschenleben
offensichtlich weniger wert war genau
das heißt also China war ja lange Zeit
eben auch Teil unserer verlängerten
Werkbank wir haben irrsinnig davon
profitiert aber das ganze ging natürlich
nur deswegen weil man so günstig und
billig produzieren konnte und diese
Zeiten sind ja nun auch so mehr oder
weniger vorbei genau weißt du was
interessantes und das deswegen sage ich
das prägt so unser China Bild aber es
hat um mal machen wir immer gerne hier
wenn wir es können Klischees schreddern
und zerstören hat mit der Realität heute
nicht mehr unbedingt viel zu tun ich
weiß ich habe vor ein paar Jahren in der
in der Mongolei haben wir gedreht ich
erinnere mich wie heute wie wir dort im
im Westen der Mongolei im altargebirge
gibt es eine Stadt es war bitterkalt -
40 Grad und wir wir kam aus diesem
Flugzeug raus und ich erinnere mich du
atmest einmal ein und plötzlich brennt
die ganze Lunge da waren unvorstellbar
stinkendes dreckiges Kohlekraft einfach
mitten in dieser Stadt und solche
Geschichten gab es eben damals auch in
China unendlich viele und ich habe
damals gedacht auch die zuständigen auch
auch die die die korrupten Gouverneure
und so weiter die haben selber Kinder
irgendwann werden deren Kinder krank
werden das werden die so nicht
durchhalten nie im Leben und genauso ist
es dann auch gekommen erinnerst du dich
in Ping hat Peking Olympia grüne Spiele
da mir damals gedacht was was das wieder
von der Propaganda Geschichte hat
Fabriken 2000 Fabriken aus der Stadt
rausgeholt Kohle Heizungen durch
Gasheizungen ersetzt da muss gab es
diese Fahrverbote nee gerade
Nummernschilder ungerade Nummernschilder
und sehr interessant das worüber wir so
viel reden aber es noch nicht wirklich
hingekriegt haben hat damals den
öffentlichen Nahverkehr vervielfacht es
gab zwei acht den Peking gerade mal zwei
U-Bahnlinien eine Runde und eine gerade
heute hast du 23 Linien
400 Stationen 700 Kilometer ist das
größte U-Bahn-Netz der Welt das zweite
ist in Shanghai ja gleichzeitig die
Mobilität verändert das chinesische
hochgeschwindigkeitszugnetz ist mit
Abstand das längste der Welt 20.000
Kilometer wo Züge mit 400 km/h fahren
und so weiter immer wir haben 2600
Kilometer auch kleineres Land aber ich
sag mal mehr als 250 km/h kriegen wir in
aller Regel nicht hin und anders als bei
uns in
98,8% der chinesischen Züge absolut
pünktlich das ist wirklich interessant
ja wir kommen ja nur das so aufzählst ne
er kommt natürlich in diese merkwürdige
Situation wenn man sagt also sowas wie
schön sind zu bauen
sowas wie diese diese Ausbau des
Nahverkehrs öffentlichen Verkehrs und so
weiter man könnte ja tausend andere
Beispiele machen also wenn es wirklich
Kampf um den Klimawandel geht dann kann
das in China alles von oben nach unten
ja durchgedrückt werden ein
Parteitagsbeschluss zack zack zack und
so weiter so und das ist was was uns in
gewisser Weise natürlich imponiert weil
wir sagen da geht noch alles bei uns
geht das alles überhaupt nicht ja dann
wird irgendwie Laden gefährdet oder
irgendwie Kröte und dann wird das nicht
gemacht oder dann braucht die Verwaltung
ein paar Jahre irgendwas zu entscheiden
und dann erhebt jemand Einspruch und
dann gibt's eine Klage und so also
dieses Gefühl in China geht alles
wahnsinnig schnell und da sind ihre
sinnige Veränderungen möglich und bei
uns geht eigentlich gar nichts mehr so
das würde die ja dann zu dem simplen
Schluss führen dass er sagen wir
brauchen irgendwie mehr chinesische
Verhältnisse in der deutschen Politik
und das ist ja gleichzeitig alles gegen
bei genau das wollen wir ja gerade nicht
also wir haben ein politisches System
das wenn man ganz ehrlich ist natürlich
sehr begabt dazu ist sich selbst glauben
zu wir haben lauter Parteien der Mitte
mehr von zwei Parteien am Rand mal
abgesehen aber wir haben 80% der Wähler
in der Mitte und wir haben ein System
die es wo diese Leute immer
gegeneinander regieren nur in dem Fall
also jetzt drei Parteien gegen die CDU
und so obwohl man wenn man in der
Regierung wäre zu 90 Prozent dieselben
Politik macht und dann ist man damit
beschäftigt der anderen das Leben schwer
zu machen und und und und und und und
und und und das ist alles natürlich
unter einen Effizienz Gesichtspunkten
ist diese Art von Demokratie nicht
effizient
das Interessante ist dass sich das
natürlich die alten Griechen schon
überlegt haben ne aristoteles hat gesagt
die effizienteste Regierungsform ist nur
Monarchie also ein Autokratie China die
Diktatur
aber sie ist auch gleichzeitig diejenige
die am ehesten in den Wahnsinn und ins
verbrecherische und so weiter abdriftet
das heißt die also von von ihrer
Ausrichtung her die instabilste ist ja
also das kann für das Land den größten
Wohltat und das allerschlimmste bringen
und in der Demokratie kommt am Ende das
raus wo es genau umgekehrt ist das ist
sozusagen am stabilsten also am
geringsten die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
ganz großer böser Missbrauch stattfindet
aber gleichzeitig im uneffektivsten und
das ist so ein bisschen die Lage von dir
wir gegenwärtig stehen ne wir hätten
gerne etwas mehr Zucht wie in China und
gleichzeitig wollen wir diesen ganzen
Mist der mit China in Verbindung
gebracht wird zu Recht ja also eben
Einschränkungen der persönlichen
Freiheiten und Unterordnung ist
Individuums und unter ein verordnetes
Gemeinwohl Einschränkung der
Pressefreiheit radikale Verfolgung
anders denken dabei Beispiele Kuchen und
so weiter und so das alles wollen wir ja
nicht und jetzt stehen wir hilflos
zwischen zwei Polen und uns ganz ehrlich
sagen wir sind zu tief vor sich sicher
wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht mehr wie
und wo wir hin wollen ich habe schon vor
Jahren mich mal gewundert meiner
Veranstaltung in Hannover und da hat der
damalige
Verbandsvorsitzende eines großen
wirtschaftsverbandes in Niedersachsen
Werbung für Kinder gemacht also ich
begeistert daran das ist jetzt fünf
sechs Jahre her was dazu eigenes
unfassbar geht und so weiter und sich
eben aufgeregt darüber dass wir uns
politisch völlig ausbremsen und das
große Innovationen in Deutschland
eigentlich nicht mehr möglich sind das
war so das erste Mal dass ich jetzt von
jemandem der auch mit CDU-Mitglied war
und auch glaube ich Ämter hatte und so
weiter so was gehört habe da so ein CDU
man sich für China begeistert und in den
letzten zwei drei Jahren ist mir das bei
konservativen ganz ganz oft begegnet ja
dass man denkt mein Gott wir verlabern
und verhindern hier irgendwie alles wir
sind nicht wir werden abgehängt und so
weiter wegen unserer Demokratie und
Bürokratie die man ja gar nicht mehr
voneinander trennen kann und in der
jeder Fortschritt ausgehebelt wird und
diese Klage hört man ja immer und
überall ja und gleichzeitig gibt es ja
nun wirklich innenpolitisch nichts an
China ja was man sich ja ernsthaft
wünschen möchte ja ist richtig ich bin
sehr gespannt wie wir da irgendwie aus
diesem diesen gedankensalat quasi
rauskommen ja aber um den Gedanken Salat
sozusagen oder den den Konflikt in dem
verstecken noch mal ein bisschen
deutlicher zu machen ich meine auf der
einen Seite die Hälfte aller
Überwachungskameras auf diesem Planeten
hängt in China rum die Hälfte in keinem
anderen Land der Welt sind so viele
Journalisten im Knast wie in China ja in
China hat massive Probleme ein ganz ganz
vielen Punkten und ich glaube wir
sollten uns mal klar machen ich habe
noch nicht mit meinem Sohn darüber
diskutiert er sagte Papa weißt du der
große Vorzug einer Demokratie gegenüber
einer Diktatur oder eine Autokratie ist
dass du in einer Demokratie kannst du
nur so korrupt sein bis es dem ersten
Staatsanwalt auffällt in einer
Autokratie in einer Diktatur kannst du
so korrupt sein dass es den Typen über
dir gerade nicht störth und so geht das
bis nach oben hindurch und das hast du
sozusagen auch bei Putin und das führt
dann dazu dass da am Ende oben Leute
sitzen und ich glaube die Gefahr hat
hier gerade auch
dass dir keiner mehr die Wahrheit sagt
Putin dachte er reformiert seine Armee
mit unglaublich vielen petromilliarden
und Abermilliarden in Wahrheit hat er
wahrscheinlich irgendwie Schiffe
irgendwo auf Malta finanziert ja und die
Leute haben sich die Milliarden einfach
eingesteckt und ich glaube die Gefahr
hat der gerade auch auf der anderen
Seite wenn du sagst von oben Ansagen ich
meine mich beeindruckt das wenn ich höre
dass 99% aller Elektrobusse weltweit
sind in China unterwegs ja das haben die
einfach mal so angesagt mich beeindruckt
wie viele Menschen die Chinesen aus
petersdamut befreit haben so innerhalb
sehr weniger es ist wahrscheinlich
diesbezüglich die größte
menschheitsleistung der Geschichte das
erkläre Wahrscheinlichkeit zweites
Beispiel das hunderte Millionen von
Menschen aus der Armut befreit worden ja
und zwar als wie Tastatur also ich
erinnere gerne daran dass in der Zeit
des großen Sprung nach vorne wie das
damals unterm hieß mil Millionen von
Chinesen ja verhungert sind China war
ein Hungerland das über viele Jahrzehnte
kommunistischer Diktatur nicht in der
Lage war seine Bevölkerung zu Ende muss
man einmal kurz erklären die Idee dieses
Großen Sprungs nach vorne es waren in
den 50ern meine ich ne war ja zu sagen
in jedem Dorf ein Stahlwerk das war die
Idee und jetzt hatte Mao einfach so
angesagt also Industrialisierung um
jeden Preis mit mit der Folge dass die
Leute nicht mehr sich um ihre
Landwirtschaft um ihre Felder gekümmert
haben und am Ende schlicht an Hunger
gestorben sind und mutmaßlich man weiß
es nicht so genau ich habe neulich eine
Zahl gelesen hat mich so beeindruckt 45
Millionen Tote auch nicht so genau
vor langer Zeit dieses berühmte
schwarzbuchkommunismus und da wurde
sozusagen aufgezählt welches System wie
wo wann wie viel tote fabriziert hat das
sind natürlich immer sehr sehr
schwierige Zeiten ne weil
darüber hat keiner Statistik geführt
richtig kann man nur sehr sehr grob
schätzen aber es wäre doch auch egal ob
es am Ende 12 Millionen oder 45
Millionen es ist trotzdem eine
unglaubliche Katastrophe wenn man
überlegt wo China heute steht genau und
dass das nicht unbedingt hätte sein
müssen dass sie das waren schon
gigantische Katastrophen die dieses Land
erlebt haben ganz schlimme Verehrungen
Kulturrevolution das gleiche da hast du
dann ne zwischen 66 und 76 ungefähr bis
zum Tod von Mao
wo auch die der schwanken die Zahlen
total krass zwischen Hunderttausenden
und vielen vielen Millionen keiner weiß
das so genau deswegen hast du völlig
recht mit deiner Anmerkung aber dann
sich zu korrigieren und zu sagen pass
auf wir wir merken dass mit der Umwelt
das geht so nicht mehr weiter wenn du
mal überlebst 2017 das ist eine Zahl die
ich da habe das ist irre hat China mehr
Geld in erneuerbare Energien gesteckt
als die USA die gesamte EU und Japan
zusammen
neun der zehn größten Hersteller von
Solarkollektoren sind in China fünfzehn
größte
das gleiche Jahr 5 der 10 größten sitzen
alle dort also das ist wirklich
wahnsinnig beeindruckend die haben keine
Lobbys das bestehenden das ist ja bei
uns so ich meine erneuerbare Energien
wir wissen ja selber wie schwer sich die
großen Energiekonzerne sehr sehr lange
dazu gegen getan haben riesige
Investitionen und dann gab es ja Geld
das konnte man drucken mit den alten was
man hatte mit Kohle und mit Kernkraft
und so und die die sitzen ja die haben
ja macht ja die haben ihre Leute in der
Politiker enorm erfolgreicher Lobbyismus
der immer auch Innovation auffällt
und das ist natürlich was was es in
diesem System ja an dem wir viel zu
kritisieren haben aber systemisch
gesehen eigentlich so nicht geben kann
genau aber was was halt interessant ist
wenn du dir dann mal anguckst wenn wenn
da jemand dann den Schalter mal umlegt
jemand wie ich hier und da ganz
strategisch rangeht und ich mir so
dieser Satz hängen geblieben ja die die
Kapitalisten in ihrer unfassbaren Gier
wir wollen immer Geschäfte machen ja die
verkaufen uns auch noch den Strick an
dem wir sie irgendwann aufhängen werden
ja das ist so ein berühmter Ersatz der
Linien irgendwie zugeschrieben wird aber
ich habe immer das Gefühl so jemand wie
sie der denkt da ganz ähnlich und
erinnerst Dich die große Seidenstraße
Initiative da denkt man so ganz naiv na
gut da wird eine ordentliche
Bahnverbindung irgendwie von von
pekingen nach Duisburg gebaut zum
Beispiel ja wir tun
Duisburg steht da nicht im Hauptfokus
gar nicht Hamburg Verbindungen nach
Hamburg Flughäfen und Autobahnen in
Pakistan Edelstein
Mineralien aus Kasachstan Tadschikistan
Usbekistan das gesamte Programm
ölterminals raffinerin im Iran ja
Zusammenarbeit mit der Mongolei und
Russland im Bereich Atom Wind
Wasserkraft der hafenkraftwerke
so Kabelnetze in Afrika ja
Hochgeschwindigkeitszüge in Ungarn und
und und und und und das Gefühl oh Mann
da gibt's einen großen Plan aber weißt
du was das Ding ist Richard vielleicht
noch zum Schluss kurz angesprochen
interessant ist
china hat große Probleme
Demografie ist zum Beispiel eins davon
ich meine in diesem Jahr kam das erste
Mal die Meldung China ist geschrumpft
ich glaube nur um 860.000 Menschen das
ist bei bei 1,4 egal aber es ist
geschrumpft es wächst nicht mehr und
Indien ist die Macht die die
bevölkerungsmäßig bald überholen wird
und die Frage ist wenn wir China schon
nicht mehr auf unsere Seite ziehen
können sollten uns vielleicht mal
intensiver mit Indien beschäftigen das
ist das eine und wenn du diese
Demographie die anguckst das ist
wirklich beeindruckend diese ein Kind
Politik die ist da lange gab er hat mir
die Zahlen mal angesehen noch vor
wenigen Jahrzehnten kriegten die
Chinesen auf Chinesen auf auf 1000
Menschen 20 Kinder pro Jahr
dann ging es runter auf 13 beim
anzahntritt von he und mittlerweile sind
sie runter auf 7 7,5 das heißt den gehen
irgendwann nicht nur die Leute aus
sondern die Bevölkerung wird wahnsinnig
alt dazu haben sie eine riesige
Immobilienblase ja zwei Drittel der
chinesischen Mittelschicht hatte ihr
Geld oder hat ihr Geld in Immobilien ja
dieser riesige Konzern evergrandy je
nachdem wie man sie ausspricht
Staatskonzern Schulden von 300
Milliarden Dollar den gehörten
Fußballclubs und
Filmproduktionen und alles was du dir
vorstellen kannst aber die stehen
komplett mit dem Rücken zur Wand und ein
großer Teil ich glaube ein Drittel der
ist der gesamten Wertschöpfung in China
kommt über Immobilien und das
funktioniert plötzlich nicht mehr das
heißt die haben echte ernsthafte
Probleme und in Afrika auch interessant
gibt es offenbar seine neue China
Müdigkeit
Afrikaner finden das auch nicht mehr so
knorke ja es gibt ein paar total
interessante Beispiele im letzten
Wahlkampf in Kenia gab es die Situation
dass der Mann der jetzt Präsident ist
William routo ja der hat ein Tabu
gebrochen der hat nämlich mal die
Eckdaten dieses
milliardenkredits mit den Chinesen für
den Bau einer Bahnstrecke von von
Nairobi nach Mombasa öffentlich gemacht
weil es unglaublich viel Unmut gab und
die Afrikaner die Bevölkerung mal wissen
wollte was haben wir eigentlich von
diesem Deal und es kam plötzlich raus
die haben uns 3,6 Milliarden geliehen ja
das darüber sollte man eigentlich nicht
sprechen 3,6 Milliarden aber keine
richtige bauausschreibung ja alle Güter
Technologien Dienstleistungen alles aus
China alles zollfrei die örtliche
Wirtschaft ja hat an diesem riesigen
Infrastrukturprojekt größte in der
Geschichte Kenias im Grunde
mitgewirkt und sogar diese
Schiedsverfahren aber aber die das ist
so klar in Afrika so das sind in einer
freien Ausschreibung wie wir uns das
vorstellen aber am Ende wird wird Kenia
natürlich massiv von dieser
Infrastruktur profitieren ich möchte
aber auf einen Satz aber will nur sagen
nee du hast gerade gesagt wir sollten
weil das mit China nicht mehr geht die
Inder auf unsere Seite ziehen und ich
würde gerne ein Plädoyer halten für das
Ausbrechen aus dem Schema von Seiten zu
sprechen weißt du die die bipolare
Weltordnung die das 20 Jahrhundert
bestimmt hat damals die
Auseinandersetzung Kapitalismus
Kommunismus eine ausblock auf der einen
Seite freie westliche Welt auf der
anderen Seite das war bipolar und dann
waren wir entweder auch mal auf der
einen Seite oder auf der anderen Seite
und das 21 Jahrhundert wird ganz viele
Seiten haben
und deswegen kann man auch nicht mehr
Indien auf unserer Seite ziehen dafür
ist auch schon Indien viel zu groß und
so stark wird viel zu sehr seine eigenen
Interessen bringen und die müssen dann
gucken ja wie viel sie an uns gut finden
und wie viel sie in China gut finden und
wie viel an den USA und und und und das
ist eben das interessante die die neu
Aufstellung die wird einfach sein dass
man sagt es gibt China und da gibt es
auch nichts mehr dran zu deuteln und die
werden auch größer und stärker
beeinwirtschaftlichen Problemen die sie
haben aber die werden nicht wieder in
der Versenkung verschwinden Indien wird
an Bedeutung natürlich zunehmen ich
denke gesagt immer eines Tages wenn das
Mula Regime vorbei ist sicher auch der
Iran und die waren weiß auch nicht ob in
Südamerika bloß Brasilien doch noch was
werden kann oder wie auch immer sie sind
jedenfalls ohne Afrika gibt es natürlich
auch
potenziellen schlafende riesen die auch
noch länger brauchen aber im Grunde
genommen ist diese Vorstellung einer
zukünftigen Welt ist die eines Spiels wo
ich versuche muss zu verschiedenen
Seiten auszukommen und mich nicht mehr
in ein bipolares Schema pressen kann ich
kann nicht mehr sein in einen
schwarz-weiß-schema zurück wenn ich das
mache dann wird das sozusagen auf Kosten
der eigenen politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung gehen also
das einzige was nicht mehr geht ist die
Politik des entweder oder sondern wir
kommen in einen Zeitalter des und nicht
das entweder oder und das ist vielleicht
noch mal zum Schluss gesagt das ist
letzten Endes auch unsere Chance ne also
wenn du dir das mal klar machst china
ist der größte Gläubiger auf dieser Welt
eine Billion US-Dollar ja Kredite an
Schwellenländer viele davon in Afrika
haben wir darüber gesprochen ist Sri
Lanka z.B auch Dschibuti hat neulich
gesagt wir können eure Kredite nicht
mehr zurückzahlen nicht unwichtig weil
China seine erste Auslands Militärbasis
in schibuti hat und zwar nicht weit von
den Amerikanern entfernt also es ist
sehr interessant und viele dieser
Kredite wanken gerade da gibt's schon
Aufbegehren und interessant ist wenn wir
nicht aufpassen dann gehen die anderen
da rein in Uganda wird auch so eine
Eisenbahnlinie gebaut die haben auch
keinen Bock mehr auf die Chinesen weißt
du wer das jetzt macht die Türken die
gehen da rein zunehmend Russen gehen
auch da rein und ich denke manchmal das
könnte uns Angst machen wenn man das so
hört aber ich denke immer eigentlich ist
das eine riesen Chance das wäre jetzt
unser Moment unser europäischer Moment
da reinzugehen und zu sagen was auf wir
machen das anders wir machen keine
Knebelverträge knebelkredite dafür habe
ich schon wieder zeigen oder genau
natürlich und wir zeigen euch wir lassen
mal faire Handelsbedingungen zu wir
arbeiten mal diese diese diese diese
diese grauenvollen Zollbestimmungen und
so weiter
Freihandelsabkommen den Afrikanern
erlauben ihre Zölle nach eigenem Gusto
zu machen aber waren aus afrikanischen
Staaten bei uns zollfrei machen so so
das wäre das beste was wir tun können ja
damit machen wir die die die die Bananen
aus Afrika in irgendeiner Form
konkurrenzfähig so so und das sind Dinge
die das übrigens besser als all diese
Gießkannenprinzip Wirtschaftshilfe da
mal ein Brunnen da meine Schule ich
meine jede dieser Initiativen des
wunderbar aber von staatlicher Seite und
von europäischer Seite kann man
natürlich ganz andere Dinge machen und
diese Forderung die stehen seit 20
Jahren im Raum ja und wenn EU irgendwas
versäumt hat mit all ihrem Gerede über
Marshallplan Afrika und so weiter dann
ist das eine vernünftige Afrika Politik
richtig und jetzt wäre halt der Moment
jemanden wie Paul Kagame den Präsidenten
von Ruanda sozusagen mal Lügen zu
strafen um es mal so zu formulieren der
nämlich dass er sehr interessanter Mann
der Demokrat glaube ich aber auf jeden
Fall interessante historische Leistung
geschafft hat ja richtig richtig mir
sehr sehr imponiert also ich dass der
Kanten Demokrat ist weiß ich auch aber
diesen Afrika auch mit der Lupe suchen
die Lupen rein Demokraten also die Frage
was ist der vergleichsmaßen genau ja
aber ich Einsatz zu Paul kalkarama ich
meine er hat dieses Ruanda regiert Kreis
selber tut sie die Tutsi war eine
Minderheit von etwa 10%, die von den
rohanischen Mehrheitsbevölkerung von den
Hutus abgeschlachtet wurde ja und zwar
fast eine Million Menschen innerhalb
aller kürzester Zeit also der Holocaust
Afrikas ein richtiger Genozid ja vom
aller schrecklichsten ja in ähnlich wie
eine Kulturrevolution aber die Kinder
ihre eigenen Eltern umgebracht haben und
so weiter also ganz ganz grässlich die
Flüsse waren voller Leichen und alles
und jetzt wird nach diesem afrikanischen
Holocaust jemand der zu der Verfolgten
verfilmten fast ausgerotteten Minderheit
gehört Staatspräsident und dem gelingt
die Versöhnung das wäre in etwa so als
wäre nicht Konrad Adenauer sondern David
bin Gurion ja in Deutschland Kanzler
geworden er hat bei der Gründung der
Bundesrepublik richtig es ist eine
unglaubliche Leistung und das geschafft
zu haben ist die Leistung von Paul
kalkarme der kein lupenreiner Demokrat
ist ja aber eine große Leistung
vollbracht hat genau der mit Blick auf
auf China und Europa irgendwie mal ein
sehr interessanten Satz gesagt haben
soll mit dem Motto wenn ihr Europäer
hier bei uns ankündigt was zu machen
während ihr einen Fahrradweg baut haben
die Chinesen uns schon zwei Flughäfen
hingestellt und das sollten wir jetzt
ändern und da hätten wir jetzt die
Chance reinzugehen und vielleicht
gelingt es ja wer weiß wenn man das eine
mit einem anderen verbindet das schaffen
wir natürlich nur wenn wir das auch im
Inland inzwischen mal wieder hinkriegen
würden
also die Afrikaner erwarten dass wir ja
großartige Infrastrukturprojekte in
Afrika schaffen die wir schon bei uns im
Inland nicht mehr hinbekommen eben was
würde Helmut Schmitter zu sagen Richard
ich glaube die Journalisten werden und
das Problem nicht lösen aber ich glaube
dass eine langfristige Lösung
darin steht das Deutschland seine Rolle
gegenüber China und definiert
wunderbar Richard danke Dir sehr
demnächst in ihrem Theater Richard David
Precht als Helmut Schmidt kein Spaß
gemacht ja also tschüss tschüss
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]